("Ready To Go" by King Sol)
- Little bit of
a pissed off mood.
Thought I could get
some more things done today.
We can be 20% owners,
50% owners or 0% owners,
here are the prices, right?
And you make a lot
of profit there, right?
But you have to make this
$1.5 million investment for us
to even consider this.
What I am saying is if you're
already massively ROI positive
with the sponsorship (censored)
well then (censored)
as long as a short term
profitable we're in a good spot.
So just super excited
about getting into a new genre.
Obviously, now
with the PureWow asset,
I'm playing in
the publishing arm.
And so, deploying my
talents on strategy and
business against
a huge platform.
One of the largest female media
sites and I'm very confident
that much like the wine business
and the advertising business and
the every business I touch good
things are going to happen and
so I'm really enjoying the
intermingling and strategizing
with Ryan who's an incredibly
accomplished CEO who took that
from zero to what it is and I'm
excited for him to see the value
that I'm providing.
In the way that I see the
world and different strategies.
I think a lot of
times people zone in
on my hustle as
my differentiator.
If you're deploying
massive hustle
against bad ideas, you lose.
So, I need to start,
I almost downplay
my strategic ability
because I think there's some
natural talent in that and
I want to give advice
that is more controllable
and I think work ethic is that.
I just genuinely
don't think you develop,
you can get better strategically
but there's a
lot of talent in it.
So I don't go there but
it's a part of my equation.
We didn't get here by accident.
These were good ideas.
It was a good idea to a launch
a website in 1996 instead
of a second liquor store.
99% of the market
launches a second liquor store.
It was a good idea to take a lot
of the money that was going to
catalogs and direct mail and
put it into Google AdWords.
99% of the market
was doing catalogs.
It was a good idea to start
a wine show on YouTube and
everybody told me I was crazy.
Even my inner circle because,
what was the value of that?
And it was a good igea.
(laughs) Igea and idea
that I did that web show.
I mean I could go on forever.
("Ready To Go" by King Sol)
Headed to Facebook
for a series of meetings.
And some biz dev and then
we're going to head down to
San Francisco for
a series of meetings.
Catch up with some startups that
I'm invested in and then head
back up here and
have some meetings.
Meetings on
meetings on meetings.
- [DRock] Still
like the heaphones?
- Still like? They've
become one with my ears.
I'm getting close to
like just sleeping with them.
I can't believe I'm
speaking in Romania.
I'm excited about that.
I don't know if
I've been to Romania.
This is funny.
900 business
professionals, one day.
Is my mom behind
this amazing hype video?
("Jump Off" by Fiifi Jr.)
They're gonna let you,
I feel like a
camera here feels so weird.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- You're at some point gonna
have to get out and get that big
sign that says
Facebook 1 Hacker Way.
Did you see that sign?
- [DRock] No, I didn't.
- The main where we walked in.
It's so epic.
I think it's
very black and white.
I think that I live in a world
where my friends are the Warbys
and the Ubers, and the airBnBs.
I wrote the first check into
BirchBox and I watch all these
behaviors and it's working.
It's the weirdest life.
My calendar so funny, right?
I'll sit with a company that
gone from zero to $130 million
in revenue on the back of
Facebook ads mainly or something
else and then I going to another
meeting and they're spending 50%
of their money buying
programmatic digital banners.
And they're like proud
that they've gone digital.
And so, were having
incremental conversations versus
the actual conversation.
Which is how in the world can we
sit here in January 2017 and not
understand that the behaviors
that we're doing are not working
when all the macro data
shows that they're not working.
It's not working.
Space is struggling.
CPG is getting, CPG I'm just
bringing back to that just so
you have empathy.
Everybody's got
their own headaches.
The channel conflict war of CPG
and their retailers in the next
20 years is gonna be insane.
If nothing else, as
big as your companies are,
doesn't it make sense for you to
do true A/B testing and put real
money behind something like
whether you believe in Facebook
or Twitter or whatever
the hell you think,
Snapchat, I don't care.
Isn't it just interesting to
find out if that's a truth.
To me, that's
been the big punchline.
It's financially smart
just to call their bluff.
Nothing scares me, DRock.
I'm the least scared guy you
know when it comes to business.
Heights I'm scared shitless.
- [DRock] You don't
like roller coasters?
- No, I hate 'em.
- [DRock] Really?
- Yeah, I don't like 'em.
- [Tyler] What about a
water slide at a water park?
- I love water parks.
I would do, there's
something that happens with
water that doesn't scare.
Like, I'll go on those
really Wet 'n Wild like phew,
I'm fine.
But on roller coasters
I don't like it for some reason.
Maybe I feel more,
I'm trying to figure it out.
Am I more in control?
I don't know.
That's an important variable for
me for continuation that we can
design and get
things up within an hour.
You know?
Oh, I want my team to des,
I want one of the
three of us to design.
Yeah, I don't know about that
but find out right away and
get back to me, okay?
Yes.
One of three guys on
design team are going to do it.
I'm gonna have
DRock text them right now.
The design will be
done within an hour.
Okay. Bye.
Wow, I didn't know that.
- [DRock] What?
- You see that? Watch this.
It stops it.
- [Jon] What does?
- [Gary] The AirPods.
- [Jon] Oh,
when you take it out?
- [Gary] And then...
- It knows? Got it.
That's real technology.
Best product
since the iPhone itself.
Cool.
So, I just wanted to say what's
up and let you guys know that
I'm about to do a
20 minute meeting
giveaway with me on Instagram.
About to put up
important quote card.
Quote picture and I'm recalling
the 60 Second Club so I highly
recommend 2,400 of you and go
and activate your notifications.
And I am going to post it
in the next very short bit.
I have a call in four
minutes and then after that
so maybe 19 minutes or so.
- [DRock] If that's
what you want.
- [Gary] I don't know.
("Pocket Change"
by Bryan J Narcisse)
Hey guys, it's Gary.
I'm just joining.
How's it going, my man?
- Good to see ya.
- [Gary] Good to see you.
How are you?
- It's been a while.
I only see you on your living
your life through Instagram.
- [John] Hey, how's it going? John.
- [Gary] John. Gary.
- Nice to meet you, Gary.
- [Gary] Real pleasure.
How are things?
- Not too bad.
- [Gary] Good.
- [Matt] Welcome to June.
- [Gary] It's great to be here.
Fired up.
How is it going?
- Good.
We're hanging out in
there if you want to put--
- Is that where we're going?
- [Matt] Yeah.
- It's insane.
He hit me up the other day
and he's like bro,
he texts me like, "Bro, I just
put two eggs into a bowl and put
"it in June. The greatest egg
dish of all time came out,"
or something like.
- [Matt] Keep it in.
- Keep the magic?
- [Matt] Yeah.
- Awesome.
- Let's go hang in the room
and we'll come back
here in five minutes.
- [Gary] Cool.
- [John] Absolutely.
- [Gary] See
you in a little bit.
- [Matt] Awesome.
- [Gary] See you in a sec.
- [Matt] We'll go in a
room that's not a room.
- [Gary] Cool.
See you later, DRock.
Hey guys, I'm here at June.
One of the, actually I think
June was the first investment
I made in the Vayner/RSE fund
because I made the commitment at
SXSW and then I had to drag
you out to actually give you the
money 'cause it took like four
months longer to do my fund.
- [Matt] Yeah.
- My deal.
- [Matt] You asked
me for a favor.
- Mhmmm.
- [Matt] Like, "Matt,
I've known you a long time."
I claim I'm the guy who
installed Twitter on Gary's
iPhone so that's
my thing in life.
Not just my claim
to Gary, just life,
biggest claim to
fame but you were like,
"Matt, I've known
you a long time.
"We are good for
commitment. I will invest.
"It's not gonna come until
seven, eight months after it's
"supposed to but I'm
good for it. You know that."
I'm glad you we're here to work.
- [Matt] "Please
let this happen."
- Yep.
- [Matt] And I did.
- [Gary] That's
exactly what happened.
- We literally kept
the round open for you.
- [Gary] I remember it.
- You were last to fund and
you were true to your word.
- It's true. So that's
where I am right now.
We're producing some content.
It is pretty amazing and
I think a lot of you will get it.
- [John] Nice. Good to go?
- [Man] Yeah.
We're all set.
- And AJ's obsessed with it.
Like completely obsessed.
I always think you need to have
a gateway product to get you
into where the world is going.
It's fascinating to me of how
I tell some of my
friends about June.
I'm like, look, you need a June
not just because you should be
cooking your food more
efficiently or you should be
saving money over
a one year period.
But you was a human should start
getting adjusted to the reality
that society we're going to work
and live within over the next
three, four, five decades and
I actually generally
believe the following.
Just like I believe about the
iPhone which
played out to be true.
That people that work and
interact with things like June
or an Alexa or things of that
nature are actually just gonna
have better lives
over the next two,
three decades 'cause they're
gonna be faster movers in the
smart-ification of
all of our products.
Yeah, no worries mate.
- [James] Love
some your work, man.
- Thank you, man.
What's your name?
- [James] James.
- James.
- [James] I read
what was your book,
Crush It!
- Crush It!
- [James] Yeah, a
couple of years ago--
- Thank you.
- [James] and loved it.
- Thank you so much.
- [James] It was a
real inspiration honestly.
- Thank you, bro.
Yeah, let's do it.
- [James] And love
your videos and everything.
- Thank you. You
want somebody to take it?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Trouty's very
good at taking photos.
- It's a pretty
shitty camera but--
- It's alright.
- [Jon] I got a couple there.
- [Both] Good.
- How did the video go?
- Went really well.
- Nice.
- I can do the video thing.
- Yeah, yeah. You're
experienced on that front.
It's a real pleasure, man.
Thanks for saying hello.
I appreciate the kind words.
- Yeah, yeah.
Focusing manually or is the
camera just not very good.
The focus is
really bad sometimes.
Have you ever tried a Canon?
- [DRock] Manually.
- Eat it, DRock.
- [Gary on Phone]
I got another idea.
Idea number two.
And this is fucking big.
(Lisa laughs) I'm telling you, Lis.
(group laughter)
Guys, honestly,
it's really big though.
Yep, you know this.
- What'd you say?
"Oh he's up."
- Guess what I came up with.
- [DRock] Oh my God. The best.
- [Gary] One,
Tyler just showed me.
You'll get an email
you're approved for CES.
That's all set.
Number two...
Cool, the same page, alright.
Love you, see you.
Bye.
When you learn how to turn the
cliche 45 minute fucking meeting
that all these fucking assholes
are doing every day into,
let me use the real data.
Into four minute
phone calls, you win.
But you're way worse than AJ.
I remember AJ's feedback.
We actually have a ranking
system of every human being.
- [Matt] That you
play basketball with?
- We have a CRM of people's
pick up basketball skills.
That's basically
how we judge people.
You in my phone it says
Matt Van Horn but you know where
company instead it just
says F- basketball player.
(group laughter)
- AirPods, the best.
- The single best
product since the iPhone.
- I literally said
best product in 10 years.
I keep saying you
look stupid as shit in it.
- I tweeted that today.
Best product
since the iPhone itself.
I can't--
- It's so useful.
- It's been so much
better than anticipated.
- Yeah.
- They nailed it.
- Yeah, I agree.
- This is surreal. I just
saw DRock's Snapchat.
- (laughs) Yep.
- And I was like I
live right here so I had to.
It was was an hour ago too
so I didn't know
if I'd see you but...
Want to go try and hunt
down Mr. Gary Vaynerchuk.
Hey Gary.
- 'Sup man?
- This is surreal, man.
I was like I didn't know if I
would see you but oh my God,
I have to Snap this too.
- [Gary] No worries.
- Hell yeah.
- What up, Snapchat?
Real pleasure, man.
- Let's do this too.
- [Gary] Uh-oh.
- [Gary] What's your name?
- Bilawal.
- [Gary] Bilawal,
real pleasure, man.
Thanks for the love.
- Thanks.
I used to work at Deloitte
Digital doing all this kind of
emerging tech stuff.
- Yep.
- [Bilawal] Really hot on VR.
Watched a lot of your videos.
Now run my own small
studio, making money,
having a good time, man.
Thank you so much
for the inspiration.
- My pleasure.
- I can't wait to see where it
goes and I know you been talking
about it but you kind of
stopped covering it after a bit.
- [Gary] Yeah.
I ebb and flow.
- Yeah. I see.
- [Gary] It's very
much top of mind.
You've also heard me say that I
think VR consumer is going to be
a little bit longer than
a lot of my friends think.
- Right.
- [Gary] But it's coming.
- It's a long play, obviously.
- [Gary] It's a long play.
- But it's the next
big computing platform.
- [Gary] 100.
It was the thing that will
arbitrage the internet itself.
- Thank so much, my man.
Cheers.
- Continued success.
Thank you.
- [Bilawal] Best of luck.
- Take care.
- [Tyler] See your brother.
We're this way.
- That's why I'm really trying
to figure out how all this plays
out because I'm not gonna be
somebody that people are excited
to meet because I can hit a
baseball 500 feet or because
I'm a smoke show and gorgeous.
- You're pretty good looking.
- I get it.
But I'm hoping,
that's emerging a little bit.
But it's because
I'm doing a good,
it's different.
It's different.
And most people that do what
I do that's different
charge people for it.
- [DRock] Cash in.
- Yeah.
- And so when you take
the compounded I understand
distribution in today's
world better than most.
I'm charismatic enough and a
good enough
communicator to pull it off.
My intent is pure as fuck.
I'm not asking for anything in
return and it's predicated on
something that makes
your life way better,
that's why I'm like fuck,
this is gonna get surreal.
("Pocket Change"
by Bryan J Narcisse)
Good to be here.
Hey guys.
- We welcome everybody.
- Okay. Do you have a rule?
- So this is office space.
We've got section here,
we've got that section there.
- Mhmmm.
- So we've got so this is the
data science tech and
we've got sales and accounting.
- [Gary] I'm Gary Vaynerchuk.
I'm the disproportionate
worst student here.
I went to Mount Ida College.
I desperately tried
not to go to college but
my mom wouldn't
let me pull that off.
This is the biggest investment
I've ever made in a company.
Period.
What I've framed my company,
VaynerMedia which is 700 people
at this point, five offices,
four offices really
is a Honey Empire.
And I think that's what
you're actually building.
You're building the tool that
I need to build my Honey Empire.
A Honey Empire is a company that
wants to destroy every single
company it competes with 'cause
it wants to be an empire and it
wants to do with by making
people feel awesome and
by empowering
their teammates and
by starting with
honey instead of vinegar.
I think HR is offense.
I think 99.9% of
people think of HR as defense.
My greatest boo moment of
speaking was when I took the
stage at SXSW and shortly
after Steve Jobs died I said,
"Fuck Steve Jobs. I have no
aspiration to be like him.
"Because I did not like the
way he treated other people."
And I feel that you can build
a trillion dollar company by
treating people
phenomenally well.
And that honey always beats
vinegar and then times like this
in our world, that a lot of my
friends on certain political
issues are unfortunately
disappointing me at a scale
that I didn't
expect because they're
deploying vinegar
to go after vinegar.
And it's honey that always wins
and so I was super passionate to
be involved in this company.
I have no idea if
HiQ wins. I really don't.
I desperately hope so
for all of you and me.
Desperate.
The company that looks like HiQ
in 2024 that wins is one of the
biggest companies in the world.
Period.
Because it's tens and tens
and hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars that are
saved and companies are empires
and they care about that.
And it's honey.
It makes people feel good.
The number two
person in my company
is our Chief Heart Officer.
We don't even call our HR HR.
What do we call it? PET?
- People and Experience.
I don't care as long as
it wasn't called HR because
everybody has it
branded this way.
There is no company that I'm
involved with that the people
around the room and say the
things that hit me in my heart.
They had me my wallet,
the hit me in my brain,
they hit me in my
competitive spirit,
they hit me my salesmanship but
they don't hit me in my soul.
This is super
what it's about for me.
And I've been doing this
in a non-scalable way.
In 2009, I would look at my
employees Twitter accounts and
give them tickets to
unfortunately the Cardinals in
this scenario and give them
tickets to a Cardinals game and
I promise you...
Who still works at our company,
I think if I gave him four times
financial raise versus those
tickets it wouldn't have had
anywhere close to the impact.
People want to be
heard and cared for.
That's why big data synthesized
properly at
scale is the ultimate.
So, I'm excited. Cool.
(group applause)
Have a great day guys,
thanks for having me.
("Ready To Go" by King Sol)
GaryVee is
going to buy the Jets.
I'm just trying
to buy a Range Rover.
(group laughter)
Cheers. Great day.
- Yep.